i've uncovered something about silicon
valley tech companies that nobody is
talking about they all capitalize on the
same three basic principles did you know
that apple generates enough profit every
single year to buy the entire airline
industry in the united states united
delta southwest and american airlines
are truly massive companies operating
some of the world's most impressive
machinery but they haven't been able to
successfully capture the value of what
they create in the same way that tech
companies have why is this it's
impossible to understand tech company
valuations by just looking at one thing
but there are three laws that combine
important properties that make them
unique and which together explain why
silicon valley companies have been able
to achieve incredible levels of success
and profitability to understand the
first law we have to go back in time to
bell labs and what became the most
notorious and dramatic betrayal in the
history of silicon valley in the middle
of the 20th century bell labs was
performing the world's most cutting edge
scientific research the list of
technologies invented by researchers
working at bell labs is breathtaking
radio astronomy the laser information
theory the unix operating system
programming languages like c plus plus
but the most important was the
transistor jointly created in 1947 by
william shockley john bardeen and walter
bratton the transistor made modern
computing possible shockley was a
brilliant scientist whose status
approached the divine but by all reports
he wasn't easy to get along with by 1953
he had fallen out with his colleagues at
bell labs and left to return to caltech
but he couldn't stop thinking about the
transistor and how it could be improved
backed by his friend arnold beckman who
was a great inventor in his own right
shockley opened the shockley
semiconductor laboratory in a small lot
in mountain view in 1956. by september
the lab had 32 employees the standards
were unbelievably high shockley hired
all of the smartest scientists he could
find many of whom compared getting a
phone call from him to talking with god
later that year shockley was awarded the
nobel prize for physics shared with his
former colleagues bardeen and bratton
ensuring their scientific immortality
but before long things at his lab
started unraveling remember how i said
that shockley wasn't the easiest guy to
get along with yeah he was a tyrant he
staged public firings he laughed at one
scientist for agreeing to work for too
little money at one point he even tried
to force his entire lab staff to take a
lie detector test shockley's young
researchers were well shocked they soon
realized they needed to get out of there
before his behavior killed their passion
for science huddling over lunch after
one especially bruising confrontation
eight of them julius blanc victor
greenwich john ernay eugene kleiner jay
last gordon moore robert noyce and
sheldon roberts decided to seek out
arnold beckman who technically managed
shockley with an ultimatum either
shockley goes or we go after hearing
what these rebels had to say beckman
initially agreed to shift shockley out
of his management responsibilities but
within a few days he lost his nerve
shockley may have been a tyrant he
reasoned but he was a brilliant tyrant
and besides beckman didn't have any
outside investors holding him
accountable he could dodge unpleasant
decisions he informed the rebels that
they'd have to deal with the situation
themselves
unsatisfied the eight young scientists
went back to the drawing board
eventually they hit on a possible
solution eugene kleiner had a connection
via his father to a new york investment
firm named hayden stone he proposed to
write the firm explaining the situation
and requesting assistance surely a
well-to-do investment firm could find
new roles for these brilliant young men
the broker who'd worked with eugene
kleiner's father was getting ready to
retire so he passed the letter to a
young associate arthur rock as it
happened rock was the perfect person to
receive the rebels proposal two years
earlier he'd worked on a funding package
for general transistor the first
independent manufacturer of germanium
semiconductors so he knew about the
promise of this emerging technology and
he also knew about william shockley's
reputation to rock the fact that these
eight guys were willing to quit working
with god was a sign of their strong
character he was intrigued he wrote back
to kleiner and before long was meeting
him and his colleagues for dinner in san
francisco rock understood that the eight
rebels wanted to continue working
together so he suggested something which
even though it seems so obvious today
had never occurred to them the way you
do this is you start your own company
that's how the rebels could work
independently what's more as founders
they would capture the true value of
their technical skills the eight
scientists were stunned the thought of
starting their own company had never
occurred to them it simply wasn't done
in the conformist 1950s
raising the money to do so wasn't
straightforward the idea of raising
money for these young scientists who
although they were brilliant had no real
profile of their own was a hard sell at
the time after approaching 35 potential
investors rock had failed to raise a
single cent then a colleague of his
suggested he approached sherman
fairchild a self-described putterer who
had inherited a fortune and was
interested in science fairchild loved
what the rebels were up to so he put in
the money they needed to start their own
company and they called it fairchild
semiconductor shockley was furious he
called the departure of the young
scientists a betrayal and predicted
their new venture would be a failure
there were many reasons he was wrong but
let's just focus on one let's fast
forward to 1965 and zoom in on a single
member of the team gordon moore moore
who by then was making a name for
himself as the director of r d at
fairchild was asked to contribute to the
35th anniversary of electronics magazine
by making a prediction about the future
of the semiconductor industry his
contribution was a short article called
cramming more components onto integrated
circuits in the paper moore observed
that the number of components in a dense
integrated circuit had doubled
approximately every year and speculated
that it would continue to do so for at
least the next 10 years essentially more
components on an integrated circuit
meant more computing power by 1975
exactly 10 years later moore had seen
enough progress in the field to revise
his forecast to say that the number of
components would double every two years
his predictions weren't based on
empirical evidence moore even called his
original forecast a wild extrapolation
but his forecast proved so accurate that
before long it was dubbed moore's law
calling it a law though didn't make it
one moore didn't actually create a
technology which allowed the number of
transistors on a circuit to double every
two years instead the semiconductor
industry adopted this as its goal
companies used moore's insight to guide
their long-term planning and set targets
for research and development almost
every advancement in modern computing
and electronics is tied to moore's law
gordon moore brought the future of
computing and electronics into clear
view he was about to bring his own
future into view as well in 1968 he and
his fellow traitorous 8 member robert
noyce decided to start a new company to
harness the innovations in
miniaturization and processing power
which the transistor had made possible
their impeccable credentials convinced
arthur rock to arrange 2.5 million
dollars to help get the new company off
the ground neuse and moore called their
company nm electronics after their last
initials but before long they changed
its name to the one it still bears today
intel intel is a truly pioneering
company in 1971 the year it went public
it created the world's first commercial
microprocessor chip its big investments
in new designs like the pentium
microprocessor in the 1990s accelerated
the rise of pcs as a viable industry it
developed the x86 family of
microprocessors which still forms the
basis of most pcs laptops and game
consoles in the run up to the 40th
anniversary of moore's article in
electronics intel put out a call for an
original issue of the magazine they
didn't have a copy and neither did
gordon moore they eventually found one
thanks to an engineer from the uk named
david clark clark started collecting
copies of electronics and other trade
magazines in the 1970s when his local
library started throwing them out
despite his wife's pleas he held on to
them for decades he ended up finding the
issue of electronics with moore's famous
article under his floorboards when he
was asked what he would do with the ten
thousand dollar reward clark said that
he and his wife intended to use it to
pay for their daughter's wedding even
when he didn't mean to gordon moore was
creating value the second law that
explained silicon valley was also born
from ambition and ego let's talk about a
guy named robert metcalf in 1973 while
working at xerox park the division of
xerox tasked with creating
computer-related products and hardware
systems metcalf and his colleague david
boggs co-founded ethernet they were
inspired by aloha net a pioneering
computer networking system developed at
the university of hawaii metcalfe grew
frustrated with xerox who despite filing
a patent application for ethernet in
1975 showed no interest in building a
business from the technology so in june
of 1979 he quit and founded 3com in his
apartment in palo alto based on his
belief that ethernet would emerge as the
standard protocol for linking pcs by
september of 1980 metcalf had set out to
raise money the mayfield fund valued
3com at 2 million dollars but metcalf
thought he could get more he declared
that 3com was worth 6 million
and that he could fetch 20 a share
metcalf wasn't exactly short on
self-confidence he was known to refer to
himself as a viking american and
admitted that he always resented mbas
because they got paid more than him and
he was smarter than them besides he knew
computer networking was a hot business
that was about to get even hotter he
noticed that vcs would always bring up
three reasons why startups like his
failed excessive founder ego
insufficient focus on the best product
and insufficient capital so metcalf
decided to flip the script he would
demonstrate his own lack of ego by
bringing in an outside executive before
proceeding with fundraising eventually a
junior partner in mayfield recommended a
guy named bill kraus they were polar
opposites where metcalf was a bold
visionary kraus was a methodical
technocrat who loved writing memos but
they also had a lot in common over
highly competitive games of tennis the
two would discuss their shared belief
that the utility of computing would be
greatly enhanced when connected with
other computers in a network that
central insight came to be formalized
and eventually known as metcalfe's law
metcalfe's law states that the value of
a network rises with the square of the
number of devices connected to it it's a
close complement to moore's law the two
exist hand in hand but there are also
important differences between them
remember that moore's law predicts that
the number of components on an
integrated circuit computing power
basically doubles every two years this
is called an exponential relationship
after two years the number of components
will have doubled after four years it
will have grown four-fold after six
years it will have grown eight-fold then
sixteen-fold and so on but if metcalf's
law was true then the value of a network
would increase with the square of the
number of users so a network with three
users is nine times more valuable than
one with just a single user while a
network with 10 users will be a hundred
times more valuable in this case
progress would be quadratic not
exponential this was possible because
networks are about the relationships
created between all users as the number
of users increases the number of
possible links between them the nodes
increases by the square of that number
dynamic and fast growing networks
connected by new technologies would
create totally unprecedented
collaboration opportunities another
major difference between moore's law and
metcalfe's law is that the latter is not
constrained by the passage of time it's
purely a function of the number of users
so if you're confident that you can
quickly and massively scale up the size
of your network then you'll be able to
capture huge amounts of value moore's
law and metcalfe's law are highly
complementary the explosion of network
size was fueled both by its growth and
utility and by falling hardware costs in
case this sounds abstract let's focus on
some real life examples social media
companies are the most famous examples
of metcalfe's law in action i think it's
fair to say that even at its peak the
value of facebook was never really about
the quality of the product we were on it
because all of our friends were there
too remember google plus it was meant to
be a facebook killer but it failed
because it could never attract enough
regular users so it was never able to
replicate the social feeling as
effectively as facebook ebay is another
cool example its incredible early
popularity can be totally explained by
metcalfe's law the more people listed
stuff for sale the more that buyers were
drawn to the site which in turn drew
more sellers who knew that they could
get a fair price in a liquid market it
was the perfect positive feedback loop
what's more because ebay owned the
network it captured all the value
created by its growth we can see
metcalf's law in places other than the
internet tesla's self-driving technology
also benefits from network effects you
might think that having 100 self-driving
teslas on the road is just 100 times as
valuable as having won but that's not
quite right tesla is betting on
self-driving technology becoming
dominant so it's important for them to
think ahead to a future where
self-driving technology is dominant by
taking the time today to learn how their
cars react when interacting with other
autonomous vehicles it's metcalfe's law
in action metcalfe's law isn't always
precisely correct but it is a great way
to understand why every type of tech
company endlessly chases new users and
subscribers and why the companies that
succeed capture huge markets and make
massive profits the third and final law
that explains silicon valley wasn't
actually discovered in the valley but
that's where it's had its most powerful
impact this law is often referred to as
the pareto principle after the italian
economist wilfred paredo you might know
it as the 80 20 rule meaning that
roughly 80 percent of an outcome results
from 20 of the inputs but it's best
known as the power law and it's the
final step to understanding modern tech
company valuations let's go back to a
man i mentioned when discussing moore's
law arthur rock i said that arthur rock
helped gordon moore and robert noyce
found intel i kind of buried the lead
though because in any honest history of
the venture capital industry arthur rock
is one of the main characters his
history of picking winners is ridiculous
in 1957 when the traitorous 8 left
shockley semiconductor laboratory rock
helped them find a place to go davis and
rock the firm he co-founded with his
colleague thomas davis jr in 1961 was
one of the biggest and most successful
early vc firms that same year he put up
280 000 to help start scientific data
systems eight years later that company
sold for 950 million dollars he was so
critical in the early days of intel he's
often given equal billing with more and
noise as a co-founder in 1978 rock
invested 57 400 in a fledgling personal
computer company with a whimsical yet
evocative name apple
the power law underpinned rock's
approach to investing for decades in a
speech in san francisco in 1962 he
explained that venture portfolios need
grand slams to average out the goofs
it's actually a great description of how
the vc industry has operated since its
inception consider this in early 2021 y
combinator's list of top companies
showed that about 5 of the more than 2
500 companies they had invested in were
responsible for generating a huge
majority of total returns the top
generated three-quarters of the returns
just three companies airbnb doordash and
stripe represented more than half of
yc's top company's portfolio value alone
bill gurley who's a general partner at
benchmark one of the top vc firms today
said it well vc is not even a home run
business it's a grand slam business but
why do such a small number of companies
consistently generate such a huge share
of portfolio returns you can see the
power law in action in other industries
but it's more prevalent in tech because
tech companies are themselves based upon
technologies that progress at
exponential rates arthur rock understood
this completely when co-founding davis
and rock he insisted that they would
only invest in ambitious high-growth
companies whose value might jump at
least ten-fold in five to seven years
most startups will fail they reasoned
sometimes it's because the technology
they rely on isn't mature yet other
times it's because they fail to
establish the use case for their product
sometimes it's just plain bad luck
therefore the winners would need to win
big enough to make a success of the
entire portfolio as davis put it trying
to play it safe in small companies is to
my mind self-defeating by realizing that
paradoxically the best way to manage
investment risk was to embrace it they
recognized the fundamental insight of
the power law if just a handful of
outliers hit grand slams and dominate
entire markets or even create new ones
from nothing then you've gotta swing for
the fences vcs don't always succeed
critics love to focus on what arthur
rock called the goofs but then most
companies don't succeed either in a
random group of 100 tech companies 90
will probably fail eight or nine of them
will deliver decent returns but because
of the power law in combination with
moore's law and metcalfe's law one or
two will probably generate insane
returns that's what explains why google
makes more profit than the entire global
airline industry and it's what vcs are
looking for when they back speculative
innovations like flying cars artificial
intelligence or elon's plan to fly a
rocket to mars their job is to look
beyond the horizon to a future that has
yet to be built understanding how
moore's law metcalfe's law and the power
law interact is key to understanding
modern tech companies one of the latest
unicorn startups to capitalize on
metcalfe's law is channel sponsor
masterworks dot io see traditionally you
had to be extremely wealthy to build a
proper portfolio of fine art but
masterworks changes that by allowing you
to invest in world famous artworks from
banksy monet and other iconic artists
for just a fraction of what these pieces
typically cost this is important because
contemporary art prices outpace the s p
500 total return by 164 percent from
1995 to 2021. the entire category has
historically required millions of
dollars to access but masterworks has a
secondary market where you can trade
shares in fine art just like buying a
stock on a trading app see masterworks
is a network effects business the more
people that use the service the more
valuable it becomes because the
contemporary art market they provide
becomes more liquid getting set up with
masterworks is extremely easy you just
create an account on their site browse
their artwork and then start
diversifying your portfolio with one of
the most stable assets around i like
masterworks because it unlocks an
entirely new market and it actually
teaches me something in the process so
go click the link in the description to
skip the wait list and help out the
channel and now that you understand the
three laws that explain modern tech
companies watch my video about the
amazing history of silicon valley next
thanks for watching